في عام 1937
بعد قرار مجلس الشورى وافق عليها الملك
عبد العزيز طيب الله ثراه ونشر في في
صحيفه ام القرى
اقر الملك بعد موافقتها على قرار مجلس
الشورى علم الملك
والعلم الوطني وعلم الملك وعلم سمول العهد
والعلم البحري والعلم التجاري وعلم الجيش
وعلم الطيران العلم في ذلك الوقت في عهد
الملك عبد العزيز والمعلومه قد لا يعرف
الكثير انه الملك عبد العزيز
العلم الخاص بالملك والعلم الخاص بسموه
ولي العهد هو ما تراه الان امامك اللي
يحمل نعم سيفاني متقاطعان او سفينه
متقاطعين يعني هذا علم الملك عبد العزيز
الخاصين متقاطعه هذه قطعه اصليه اصليه نعم
استخدمت على السيارات ترى كثيرا
الملك سعود حينما قابل العلم هذا حقيقه
حينما قابل الملك سعود الملك فيصل الثاني
ملك العراق في المنطقه الشرقيه كان هذا
العلم عندي فضول كيف حصلت عليه
كلها بالاقتناء والشراء حقيقه والانتقال
من مكان لمكان والسؤال اصبحت حقيقه يعني
محترف في مجال الاعلام انا اشتريت من
امراه بنفس دقيقه من خلال بحثي وصلت الى
امراه في امريكا مدرسه ومحل التقاعد عمرها
بالسبعين
من اكبر جامعيه صور صحيح يعني عندك هذا شق
اخر لم نتحدث عن بس لاحظت في هذا الكتاب
في كميه كبيره من الصور تضع على كل صوره
شرح تاريخي لها مناسبه التقاطها تاريخها
الشخصيات التي كل الصور مربوطه بالاعلام
وكل الصور مربوطه اول كتاب عن العالم
السعودي
نحن نتحدث عن واقع بحثي كم استغرق منك هذا
البحث ست سنوات حقيقه وفي معلومات قد تكون
يمكن يعني
من النادر وجودها يعني انا انا اللي اكون
معك اكثر صدقا يمكن لو ما اثير خلال
الماضيه موضوع يعني خطاط العلم لم ارغب
بالافصاح عن مجموعه من المعلومات
التاريخيه اللي تعبت في الحصول عليها
بسهوله حقيقه لكن العربيه تستاهل
والعلم حقه ان يشاع ويذاع يعني لكن انا ما
وجدت هذا الكتاب ان شاء الله نجده قريب في
الاسواق يعني
واتمنى ذلك ان شاء الله ان شاء الله باذن
الله لعله قريب ان شاء الله